-It is always a delight
to have you here.
The first thing I have to
ask you about --
And backstage, it was a little
jarring for me, as well.
This is the first time
a lot of people
have seen you
with hair like this.
-Yeah.
Yeah, so, about that, right?
-For all the machismo and
bravado that oozes
out of the WWE and its audience,
they're so shaken by
a damn haircut.
-Yeah.
-Guys, I've been rockin'
an $8 fade for 20 years,
and I finally decided
to grow it out.
-Yeah.
-I'm sorry to make
you uncomfortable.
I am. I'm sorry. I apologize.
-Well, I think they're
probably uncomfortable --
It's such a corporate haircut.
Like, none of us could have
guessed what it would look like.
-I'm in a damn
three-piece suit, man.
-Yeah!
-It kind of --
It's the whole Clark Kent.
I mean, this is the thing.
-Your new wrestling name
should be "The CFO."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, there you go.
-The finishing maneuver to be
"think outside of the box"?
-Yeah, think outside of the box.
And then you just toss them
out of the ring.
-Yeah, man.
Well, that's 2019 for me.
-There you go.
-Right on.
-So, this is a lot of fun.
This is sort of an origin story
for the Transformers.
It takes place in 1987.
-Yeah.
-Where were you in 1987?
-So, I was -- Man, I was 10.
-Okay.
-And '87 was a tough year...
-Yeah.
-...growing up in New England.
-Patriots just got their
ass kicked in the Super Bowl.
-That's right. Not even close.
-Yeah, I don't know if anyone
remembers the 1986 World Series,
but that was a tough time
for the Boston Red Sox.
[ Light applause ]
Don't, don't --
Are you a Mets fan?
Did a Mets fan sneak in here?
Tore my heart out!
-That was the worst for me ever,
the '86 World Series.
-Because you're a Red Sox fan.
-Yeah, I'm a Red Sox fan.
-I have since denounced
my fandom.
I am a gypsy. I'm a gypsy fan.
-You are a gypsy fan.
-Yes, I go with
the winning teams.
-See, I hung on until 2004,
and that was my sweet release.
And now I just care less,
because it let me free.
-Yes. Yes, but '86 was tough.
-'86 was tough.
-Yes.
-And you -- The nice thing about
this film is Hailee Steinfeld,
who's a fantastic actress.
-She is.
-She is the hero of this film.
-Which I love, because if this
film, which takes place in 1987,
were to be filmed in 1987,
I would be the hero,
and she would be,
like, the love interest.
-Yeah.
-But, damn it,
we're in a culture nowadays
where she can
actually be the hero
and kick some ass,
and I can be the bad guy.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you --
-Yeah. Take that, Mets fan.
I see you over there.
-Yeah, take that.
-Take that!
-Yeah.
-I'm even wearing
the Mets' colors.
This is a shame.
-Yeah, this is --
You did not play this well.
-I am covered in shame syrup.
-You know, you relish
playing the bad guy,
which I think are
the fun bad guys to watch.
-I don't re-- I mean,
I don't relish it.
-No, I think you
find the fun in it.
And you come from
a world, wrestling,
where there's
the hero and the heel,
and people take that very
seriously in wrestling.
I think, you know,
it's not just you have
the wrestlers you root for,
you have wrestlers
you actively root against.
-Yeah. And it's weird with me,
because I am supposed to be
the hero,
but I'm actually the heel.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and everybody is like,
"Man, why don't you just
turn bad so you can
be cool again?"
Wait. Wouldn't that
make me good?
-Yeah.
-I don't even know!
And it's fun to, like,
go into the WWE warp zone
with those folks.
They think I'm supposed to be
a bad guy to be a good guy,
but aren't I already
being a bad guy?
Just wait.
Just wait until
the debut of The CFO.
Give me those TPS reports!
-Wow! That is really --
This has legs.
-I think it does not.
-It does.
You just have to
wear that into the ring.
That's going to be
very uncomfortable.
-Yes it will.